bienvenue dans votre feuilleton préféré
çà çà çà çà ce n'est rien à côté des
bons écoutez je suis très content de
l'accueil vous avez fait à cette vidéo
où je pensais que j'avais le sol a adoré
ce délire vous adorez tous quasiment
alors je sais pas jusqu'où va l'histoire
mais je crois qu'elle est très très très
longue donc je sais pas on m'a arrêté
dans l'histoire à la fin de cette vidéo
et oumar et est de manière générale dans
cette série de vidéos je vous dis ça
mais il n'a pas d'aboutissement voilà
c'est juste une info je n'attends rien
de votre part juge le dit du coup c'est
inutile à l'épisode 3 au sa peau c'est
parti retrouvons une petite brune mots
o la fameuse villa que personne dans ton
post loué lors de ses vacances à ça
m'avait manqué sa douce voix orange
entend pas elle est un jeu de montage
mais je fais semblant de vivre la chose
comme vous à l'autre
oh non il est énervant celui ci et je
pense que tu n'as pas prévu de le
recevoir en pyjama j'ai pas pu le
recevoir du tout mais qu on bat les
couilles mais je n'ai rien à me mettre
pour une sortie comme celle-là a à g
devoir dépenser 5 euros pour une tenue
vous la santé ou pas mais j'ai jamais
dit oui en fait flasher bachmann en deux
quand je lui dis non tu viens de gagner
aux menaces en ville demain c'est ciao
c'est fou je dois trouver quelque chose
de spécial voilà confortable et élégant
parfait pour rio combien ça coûte vous
me ferez pas les développeurs commun ça
coûte au hockey c'est un peu bavard ce
que je fais mais je vais lui en mettre
plein la vue pour qu'au moment où il
essaie de tenter quelque chose je dise
c'est non je vais jouer avec ton coeur
rodrigo et je m'en fiche rodrigo car tu
n'es qu'un personnage fictif
croyais ap le tribunal observe toi j'ai
déjà fait un regard avec quelqu'un
l'observatoire d'une ville s'il vous
plaît voici notre liste au corcovado a
life et liquides
c'est magnifique un tapis ont été
construits
la promenade n'inclut pas l'histoire du
site miss brown on veut en savoir plus
comment se bat à faire le mec si tu sais
juste le nom du bâtiment ou à temps j'ai
un nouveau message au bruno kevin putain
mais pourquoi tu vois je crois que c'est
bruno cecchi fille tu s'il te plaît
j'appellerais sans répit aller j'ai
besoin de toi mais 29-0 tu observes ya
des jumelles ça dégage un moment mais
qu'il est lourd
j'aurais pas dit mieux je croyais que tu
n'étais pas très intéressé par la
promenade
qu'est ce qui t'a fait changer d'avis
ouais c'est bien ce que je dis j'ai pas
changé d'avis en fait tu m'as forcée ça
s'appelle un kidnapping mais qu on peut
dire que drouot idiot à une icône
méthode il peut être un peu lourd
je suis content que tu sois venu à temps
il vient de chier sur le mec qui lui a
permis de m'emmener au rancart c'est
incroyable vous pouvez continuer la
visite touristique au québec où nous
divisent les dans un autre emploi plus
certainement pas aventureux non ah
putain c'est une option payante j'ai
envie de voir les options payantes mais
d'un autre côté je veux pas donner ce
plaisir à rodrigo à je te présente la
fameuse pamela routine yao mais c'est
quoi votre truc c'est d'aller dans des
endroits dangereux c'est que vous fait
qu'il fait dans la vie nous est idiot au
sapporo s'approcher à tancer nardin
cattori tout c'est vrai là vous êtes en
sécurité maintenant les enfants qui est
au sap au méchant mais qui sait que
cette merde acquis 6 passes il travaille
sûrement pour lui au sa peau
l'exploitation des enfants et comme une
part ici
rodrigo bon temps rodrigo n'aime pas les
méchants au job cette voie alors est ce
qu on appelle la police
ou est-ce que droz yeux pourraient nous
aider à gros succès lui a bien servi ce
qu'il est capable d'aider on appelle la
police comme tout le monde
tranquillement voilà enfin la police et
michel sont corrompus je crois que les
enfants ont raison la police pourrait
être complice il vaut mieux s'appeler
derosiaux un enfant mieux vaut un
policier corrompu que d'or aux jo j'ai
besoin de ton aide
j'ai des enfants avec moi ils sont en
danger ok merci il à vis de les emmener
à la maison tout huit lots étaient
ramenés de gosse et cela doit maintenant
est ce que tu sais quelque chose à
propos de ce titre on the go désolé je
n'ai jamais entendu parler de sa peau
peut-être qu'il faudrait un jour ça
s'appelle abala ça va finir en prison
tout ça d'accord mais je retournerai
dans la favela mairie de faire il est
chiant de vouloir sauver tout le monde
je suis sûr que je veux en savoir plus
sur sa peau et ses enfants c'est notre
meilleure option évidemment va rodrigues
ansa dans la favela aux moindres à linda
s'occuper des enfants s'il te plaît ne
convient pas aux clio bien je compte uc
loire on se joua plus tard j'ai eu un
mauvais pressentiment
oui ou aller à plat rodrigo sept chats
ou à la vache tu étais d'accord qui ont
des goûts vous retourne la favela 40
saint jean ont fait ce choix on est 40 %
à se débarrasser des forces heures comme
ça olala halal à cet épisode je
l'attendais le rêve mec
linda tu ne parles pas une seule fois
dans des goûts dans cet épisode s'il te
plaît tu nous laisses profiter auquel
les enfants ne vous éloignez pas trop
bas ils viennent vraiment s'éloigner
aboud rosilio qu'est ce qu'on va faire
avec les enfants les vendre c'est quoi
ce oui on dirait un hélicoptère attend
de voir ce pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec la musique là il s'excite et là le
gars au saxo et la dram s'exciter
regardez cela lui arrive de bruno me
souffrir les parkas putain nature pas
changé nous faut que charge de montcalm
bonjour ces enfants sont à voir non pas
vraiment on les a sauvés de la favela
ils sont encore en danger et on essaie
encore de décider ce qu'on va faire je
vois il s'en bat les couilles des
enfants ça se voit vraiment brno ce
thème mais là vraiment cruelle défaite
d'un petit nombre d'hélicoptères
narbonnais là c'est trop je peux pas
accepter
j'arrive tu préfère ne pas y aller tu
acceptes c'est super il essaie de donner
envie de dépenser des diamants en disant
si super évidemment- j'accepte l'hélico
l'hélico sur l'aide de bruno savait
comment capter l'attention des gens
linda ah ça y est la traduction part en
couille il n'a pas peur de la petite
bête n'est ce pas en fait c'est avec toi
je suis au septième ciel bruno donc tu
veux je suis je suis très très heureux
pas du tout au contraire j'adore les
sensations fortes
on est arrivée bienvenue chez boire aux
attentions des raisons bruno attention
accrochez-vous bien au dessus c'est
moins bien que cynthia pas ouf
oui nous c'est incroyable je suis ravi
que ça te plaise hilda qu'est ce que tu
penses de l'ordre noir s'est passé c'est
le paradis on taira demandé de roses
blanches et tu la fermes regard de la
taille de la piscine mais ça n'a aucun
sens déjà ils ont kidnappé des enfants
vraiment et ensuite il les amène dans
leur maison de riches total dont dix aux
as raison cet endroit est un paradis
bruno c'est sûrement le paradis car je
regarde un ange
la prochaine phrase bateau que tu dis
c'est une claque tout de suite un autre
bolide dans ce cas optent les parties
tu évites de fierté du flirt avec bruno
non mais attendez le choix est vite fait
j'ai aussi fou ce que j'ai oublié mais
elle quelque part linda tu veux te
balader sur la plage pour que tu
paniques en proposant ça vous dirait que
tu veux m'attacher un art même séquestré
c'est hyper glauque mais bien suivre
pourquoi pas aller la page avec bruno la
page ça n'oublie pas vraiment à wana
quand elle découvrira ça qui est johanna
ok c'est pas grave on a eu beau tout va
bien au tennis de rodrigo marché est
creux tuyaux sa peau je réponds je me
tais je me tais mec je dirai rien on
n'est pas des balances
[Musique]
c'est étrange d'entendre autant de rires
par ici merci de les avoir invités
il en avait besoin il me rappelle mon
enfance pas du tout tu vas pas te la
jouer populaire l'a tué a grandi dans
les favelas non même si ma famille ils
n'étaient pas vraiment riche mais
dommage
tout ce que j'ai je les construis seul
en partant de rien mais dubaï désolé de
vous interrompre mais je suis inquiet
pour rodrigo peut-être je n'arrive pas à
voir aussi qu au niveau des parents très
il est dans la favela
il cherche des infos sur les enfants je
vais demander à tort mon garde du corps
d'enquêté s'appelle tort ou la joue
alors je ne pensais pas devoir partie
oui dans la merde olala ça c'est les
regards d'un homme qui est dans la merde
et qui réfléchit à calais ce que cela
pourra sortir je vais bien alors tu me
parles de suite c'est pas parce que tu
as la bouche trop fait que tu perds la
meuf pour jouer pourquoi elle dit ça à
bruno
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah suite la suite bomba à 0 5e
cinquième épisode
non mais là et nous mettrons en haleine
la chute dans la
[Musique]
vous jouez je te présente loi nâ c'est
son ex femme manager est associée au
mandat un de mes clubs johanna est aussi
chargée de trouver de nouveaux talents à
s'entendre notre carrière s'envole ont
pécho un mec qui est trop beau gosse et
on est pote avec une femme fatale mais
tout va bien et donc la mise et les
vivres en spectacle au brésil
j'adorerais voir un de ses spectacles un
de ces jours là mon temps mais d'abord
nous donnons voir le tien tu l'avais le
mien déjà je suis tombé à l'eau bruno
c'est bon tu ressasse des souvenirs
horribles
[Musique]
ce que tu demandes l'argent n'est pas un
problème je reconnais cette époque il
s'agit de kevin je te donne la moitié
demain il reste qu'une fois le travail
fait mais n'est-ce pas de jouer avec moi
qu'est ce qu'ils demandent qu'est ce
qu'ils demandent à ça devient bien
c'était lent jusque là mais là c'est
bien c'est l'homme de ma bruno est
ajouté à ceux d'office
c'était nécessaire n'a découvert le
chargement on ne pouvait pas courir le
risque
enfin le nom de disques tu doit libérer
le père contrat c'est exprès laisse le
parti sa famille a de bons contacts
il peut causer des problèmes lors de
l'opération ses poils l'opération qui ce
que c'est tout ça qu'est ce qui se passe
là whaou trop d'éléments
[Musique]
on devrait employer johanna je pense
qu'elle vaut très cher c'est moi je veux
d'abord entendre autre registre est à
tonalité arrête de faire la purée c'est
la tonalité registre allez au hasard
vous devrez savoir la différence en
toute demande et un ordre mais niktamère
bruno en fait un non non non j'ai fait
le mauvais choix
c'est clairement rodrigo le mec cool
depuis le début c'est pas du tout bruno
je me suis fait avoir par sa gueule qui
ressemblent à brad pitt est ce que tu es
encore un qui attaquent aux multiples
l'aéroport tu lui parles tu gagnes tu
lui parles pas kevin mais reste
tranquille bruno on a un petit jardin
secret je suppose que je suis plutôt
réservé ce n'est pas contre toi c'est
totalement con toi mec tu fais trop le
foot alors comme tu parles à johanna tu
m'as dégoûtée c'est l'heure d'aller les
enfants sont fatigués je suis inquiet
tout rodrigo tué à résoudre audio merci
pour tout bruno je t'emmène linda à les
ramène au beau gosse et on peut passer
du temps ensemble en rentrant voiture
les enfants sont fatigués rentrer avec
laure délie caudrot diot putain c'est
lui qui a le droit l'hélico je suis deg
en fait c'est un bon moyen de se
débarrasser d'un mec qui t'empêche de
gérer le même coup la meuf que tu kiffes
tiens prends l'hélicoptère va faire un
tour on paye pour tout de suite
ah si
comme rodrigo
mais non mais à chaque fois ils m'ont
moi j'avais pas m'arrêter là ils font
chier
à s'est fait défoncer mecque pour y
rester un continent à cause du
traumatisme du traumatisme lequel celui
que j'ai causé en le tenant à distance
ou le celui de la favela par leurs amis
par contre dit signé laissons le se
reposer il se pose pas mais qui se
repose pas li na est en train de mourir
sur le canapé c'est pas la même chose
et eux ils voient ça ça me tue sa lutte
à quelque chose ne va pas rodrigo s'est
pointé mal à ranger et la maison est en
désordre et la maison est en désordre
voilà elle mais elle met ses deux fois
les mots même level c'est terrible tu
vas bien tu veux que je viens de voir
oui et que tu m'embrasses aussi quoi
c'est si ça me ça m'aidera beaucoup
qu'il est mignon mais ce n'est pas
nécessaire non à l'état à saillir n'est
plus en accord avec menace est terrible
et rodrigo il a l'air d'être quelqu'un
d'important dans ta vie n'ont que deux
tu te trompes pas du tout bien sûr qu'il
l'est c'est le frère de ma meilleure
amie
c'est tout oui oui tu racontes ont passé
un gros ego tu change de sujet toujours
être franc il faut qu'on soit on lui
raconte mais on lui dit que c'est bien
fini et manon et clara d'accra on a une
histoire il y a des années on était très
jeune
voilà vous avez eu une relation cynthia
et moi vivions ensemble à l'université
en californie
rodrigo est allé la voir et il est resté
un peu on s'est connus comme ça deux en
suisse
que s'est il passé brad a compris mec tu
abuses à quel farceur et votre première
fois c'était qui a fait quoi ça va bruno
les choses n'ont pas fonctionné
disons qu'on est passé à autre chose
séparez moi tu es toujours amoureuse de
lui
aoued putain attendait il veut vraiment
tout savoir je tiens à lui c'est bien on
a été français la mer jaune merci d'être
gonflé linda tag est on a tous un passé
que l'on préférerait oublier
attends qu il mais quand on est juste
sorti avec un mec il ya ça fait partie
de la vie oui bof pour un peu on discute
demain
[Musique]
je mets à cache cache je ne voulais pas
vous interrompre mais pour prince
charmant t'attends à la porte
quoi aujourd'hui qu'il a pour
instruction de vendémian cada qu attend
j'aime faire kidnapper
non il devrait égaler le lion kadaré pas
d'endroit où elle conduit ici c'est quoi
le jean ghada ac le club de bruno je
crois je vais aller dans ma chambre me
changer vite fait allez on met la
meilleure j'espère que cette fois on
aura au moins un bisou parce qu'on
n'arrête pas de mettre les meilleures
tenues et pourtant et pourtant il se
passait derrière bordel waouh on est
arrivé au dojang adam shine ganache pas
comme ils s'appellent ya bruno là bas je
le vois se paie les talons qu'est ce
qu'il y a
pourquoi tu me regardent comme ça c'est
pouvoir
j'essaie de reprendre mon souffle c'est
les 5 euros ça tu as volé tous les
regards de l'assistance ça me dérange
pas d'attirer l'attention des zones de
la plus jeune que toi mais en fait c'est
excuse moi je veux que plus de produits
this is your land a maintenant pourquoi
pas
évidemment qu'on est prêts on a mis dans
bâle dans le jeu c'est pour cette raison
là on est prêt à tout ok c'est parti on
va chanter sur la scène j'ai dû payer 5
euros la prestation de linda attention
[Musique]
je chante aussi c'est je m'appelle midi
dare
[Musique]
elles sont deux
pas mal j'ai pas été pas mal j'ai été
étincelante johanna répond avec humour
quelle étrange commentaire quelqu'un
dire un truc bizarre tu lui réponds
juste quelle étrange commentaire
[Rires]
[Musique]
ah ok on est de retour ça fait plaisir
de te voir debout mais elle ouvre la
favela
j'ai été kidnappé je pensais que je ne
survit prépare mais quitte à séquestrer
wahou
ils ont mis un s acquittent à x linda
les enfants ont disparu quoi la maquette
pour moi je veux être bon coup bonjour
tu as fait de la merde là non pas la fin
d'épisode
non non bon j'ai dû m'arrêter j'étais à
deux doigts d'enchaîner encore mal et
j'ai dû m'arrêter ça fait une heure
vingt j'étais à deux doigts de lancer 7e
je vais pas vous mentir mais là il faut
arrêter là là c'est trop et ce que je
fais un troisième épisode du galon
horrible qui marche 10 fois moins que
les deux autres mais dans lequel on
finit cette putain d'histoire
j'ai envie de savoir maintenant les
enfants qu'est ce qu'ils vont devenir
est ce qu'un jour il va se passer
quelque chose entre un garçon et linda
dans ce jeu où entre une fille et
l'inavem je m'en fous mais qui se passe
un truc un petit contact physique est
mal et je vous dis à bientôt dites moi
ce que vous en pensez et ce qu'on finit
il faut finir je pense qu'on finira
butin jamais finir maintenant au vase il
faut que j'arrête là les gens rentrent
biloa
[Musique]